[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ready to game the system
meet manna you slay
you achieve you win so should your bank
account because your power shouldn't
stop when the game does
mana is the best gaming rewards debit
card where you can earn perks and points
by paying and playing and get rewarded
with the things you actually want like
that skin you can't wait to show off or
your next gear upgrade so why pay any
other way pay with mana pay with power
mana
game the system
[Music]
hey everybody i'm christopher judge
though you may know me best as the metal
myth
that a boy
god slayer
kratos
from sony santa monica's god of war
series
you didn't know my voice was actually
this deep did you
usually that costs extra tonight
i'm swapping the axe for a humble
microphone because we've got a ton of
exciting video game trailers to get
through
but like all good adventures
this one requires teamwork
in fact
i'm calling on another mighty god's
power to help me out
oh danielle
danielle
daniel
are you with me
i've always been with you christopher
it's so good to see you and for all the
folks at home my name is danielle besuti
i voiced the witch of the woods aka the
leader of the van near aka the valkyrie
queen known as the norse goddess freya
in god of war
and i don't need freya's foresight to
know that this event is stacked with
some serious amazing news that is quite
right
that's because this is the future game
show powered by mana a digital showcase
event streamed live across the nine
realms but also and exclusively planet
earth
tonight we'll be treating you to over an
hour of exclusive trailers for upcoming
video games you'll be able to find and
wish list all of the games from today's
show on the feature game show steam page
and you can head on over to
gamesradar.com
to read all about them well my darling
that was quite the intro but we best get
going thimble winter doesn't last
forever and we've got all that
unfinished business to attend to
so let's kick things off with our very
first
world premiere
[Music]
it seems that when experiencing deja vu
a strange phenomenon occurs
dude are you awake
oh come on man
we really need to talk
we just had a meeting here at niraxas
it's really bad man
[Music]
the hippocampus is an old cortical area
involved in multiple aspects of memory
formation
bridging our past with our present
experiences enables it to construct our
autobiography
there's a huge flaw they kept it a
secret for years
latest research shows that by changing
our brain waves in the hippocampal
region deja vu creates a brief gateway
to a parallel world
call me as soon as possible
[Music]
well you know in my experience it's
easier to salvage your memories when
they've been carved into ancient walls
well
not all of us have such
mythology the gap is coming soon to pc
playstation 5 and xbox series x and s
players of our next game might think
they faced every monster space has to
offer but the team behind aliens fire
team elite have a few more surprises up
their sleeve
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
where mutated gameplay of aliens fire
team elite pathogen comes to pc
playstation and xbox on august 30th
now we've got a developer presentation
from our friends at digital cyber
cherries the team behind hyper charge
unboxed you know
the toy box shooter that went viral on
twitter
[Music]
xbox players we're looking for small
soldiers
dive into the toy field and fight waves
of classic
toys your mission is to defend the hyper
core collect action figures and defeat
major evil
watch out for the cyber t-rex
boy the boss in the bathroom
and dozens of more classic toys
[Music]
the vigilant soldier the victim toy kind
is in your plastic hands
[Music]
what are you waiting for recruits
that disembodied voice sounds
vaguely familiar
hypercharged unboxed is out now on pc
and nintendo switch with an xbox and
playstation release coming soon
now here comes another shiny world
premiere for all you super sleuths out
there
[Music]
murderous mad libs with a midas touch
the case of the golden idol is coming to
pc in 2022 and we're pleased to announce
a demo is going live right now on steam
no snacks fridge empty it's time to
answer the call of the trash can
is that in the script or
are you just thinking out loud danielle
oh no it's actually the premise of our
next game
[Music]
stinky
sly
and always looking for their next meal
raccoons are a lot like us when you
think about it
snaccoon is coming soon
now
you might want to dim the lights as it's
time to soak in the dark atmosphere of
tainted grail the fall of avalon
[Music]
[Music]
you're awake
good
i thought i'd get us to fire burning it
would have been ashamed to freeze to
death what we got so far
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i found him
or what was left of him
a mile down the road
the weirdness merged him with his horse
a horrible way to die
don't you think
[Music]
tainted grail the fall of avalon is
coming to steam early access in q4 2022
our next game is steeped in secrecy
which means we can all experience this
reveal together
it's hard to say when we passed the
point of no return
but we did
we made our world uninhabitable
because for the smartest animal on the
planet
humans can be really stupid
[Music]
civilization started to creak at the
seams
and if there's one emotion greater than
greed in humans
it's fear
perhaps it came too late
but it did
and when we are afraid we get reduced to
a single instinct survival
we need land we need food and shelter
but in the end
we need each other
we need communities
we need cooperation
we need to build something together
will it be something that won't collapse
this time around
[Music]
will we ever stop being afraid
well
maybe you'll be the one to unite
humanity
and shape the society of tomorrow
[Music]
well let's pray there are no world
serpents in the water
battles at the ready because flood land
is coming soon
from one dark world to another it's time
to catch up with plot twist the
developers behind the last case of
benedict fox a spooky lovecraftian
metroidvania
[Music]
hi i'm bart creative director on the
last case of benedict's fox a
fantastical lovecraftian metroidvania in
which you dive into a twisted world of
secret organizations forbidden rituals
and cold-blooded murders
your aim is to uncover the secrets of
the mansion and the murders that
happened within these walls but to find
out what truly happened you will need to
dive deep into the memories of the
victims and visit an alternative reality
we call limbo
you see those two worlds they're linked
with each other dimension secrets will
help you out in limbo
while what you find in nimbo will help
you unlock the mysteries of dimension
i got a bad feeling about this
my my
a real gollum very difficult to pull off
and very illegal to even try
in our studio we love metroidvanias we
love how they reveal to you their world
one step at a time we wanted to take
that feeling and combine it with a great
story a mystery that also reveals its
secrets to you the deeper you dive in
it reminds him of someone silly and
denying it's annoyingly
warm to survive whatever the limbo froze
at you you can always visit our friend
harry houdini to purchase some useful
items
you can also use the demon's ink you
collect at the tattooist to unlock new
skills right now we can only afford the
slam which is still a very useful skill
to have let's absorb
[Applause]
that was the slime skill that we just
acquired
what did you think
and that's harry houdini's lockpick in
action
[Music]
resentment and fear
he survived her abuse and wears it like
a badge of honor
you may feel powerful now but remember
you're not the only one who can descend
into limbo
[Music]
[Music]
i'll take the boy
over a demon companion any day
the last case of benedict fox is coming
to pc and xbox in spring 20 23
i would also classify our next game as a
psychological thriller where you try
desperately to maintain order while at
the whim of a trixie malevolent beast
i thought this one was a cozy
condo-esque puzzler
it's up for interpretation
[Music]
yes lucas i found it
ah hey nice one annie
[Music]
this doesn't look quite right
let me show you our game while we sort
this out
we're thrilled to announce that a little
to the left is coming to pc on november
8 2022.
okay it's been fun seeing all these cool
games coming soon but i figured we could
use a quick break a change of scenery
perhaps you read my mind what were you
thinking what if i told you that there
was actually a hidden tenth realm one
drenched in neon light
plus we don't even need the bifrost to
get there
i've been to many lands but none with
this much artificial lighting
indeed
this nifty little realm is the virtual
show floor every booth you can see has a
game attached with a demo dropping after
the show for those at home which means
all of you google future games show
steam and you can download and try out
any of the games that catch your eye
all right with that in mind let's get
started with our first game this is
fairy after light a stylus metroidvania
inspired by indonesian philosophy
players will control chemo and wispy a
literally inseparable duo as they
explore the world of lumina working
together to solve puzzles and defeat
fearsome enemies
well
now i'm missing atreus all of a sudden
what's next danielle
always a good father
lovers of strategy and bootleg booze
rejoice as this game covers both an
equal measure moonshine inc is a
management sim where players battle it
out to brew the best hooch in town
players will expand their facilities and
perfect the making of mountain mash
while evading the pan-optical eye of
johnny law with genuine fermentation
processes recreated virtually this sim
is as real as it gets
just make sure you don't get caught
and now for something completely
different
yes
because we're jumping from moonshine
making to a mysterious metropolis
it's time to fear the new blood as our
attention turns to gloomwood a grim dark
ode to the immersive sims and survival
horror greats of the late 90s and early
90s
players will use all manner of victorian
era instruments to improvise adapt and
overcome a town teeming with mischievous
mobs
so what are you waiting for
grab what you can see and get to
it our next game also involves plenty of
improvisation just with a little bit
less focus on monster slang
care to do the honors
of course
this is the wandering village a sandbox
city builder set on the back of a
gigantic wandering creature called on
boo in my experience living with a giant
tortoise wasn't so bad but results may
vary here players will battle the
elements and research technologies in an
effort to revive a long-lost society
will you settle and survive in this
harsh humbling environment by learning
to bond with the beast or choose to be a
parasite leeching from its life force
the choice is yours
where are we off to next
this game is bound to strike a chord
well maybe a few demonic musicians
gather their cards in power chord a
rogue-like deck builder from big blue
bubble equip gear and create combos to
strum and roar your way through a
monster-filled battle of the bands held
in grungy grottos and hellish hole in
the walls
monsters come in all shapes and forms
from demons to dentists or at least they
do in our next game never awake
this is a twin stick shooter set in the
mind of a little girl called rem players
will battle their way through 80 levels
of her vivid nightmares
each one brimming with creepy
manifestations of everything from
vegetables to dogs and yes
even school friends
its charming art style will have you
questioning whether it's creepy
cute or a great mix of both
now if you'd rather wield fear as a
weapon then fight against it then this
next one is for you
the fabulous fear machine is a pulp
horror strategic simulation game where
players will generate terror and expand
their influence through the spread of
scary stories and creepy conspiracies
from bloody mary to reptilian overlords
let the unexplained mythos of the public
consciousness become your ammunition
what have you got for me danielle i
think the question is
what haven't i got
anno mutationum is a sleek cyberpunk rpg
that blends 2d and 3d graphics to create
a rich world that you'll just want to
dive into when you're not bartending or
dog-sitting a cyborg corgi you'll be
slashing your way through cybernetic
monsters and pursuing criminals in the
underbelly of this atmospheric vibrant
neon metropolis
our next game will teach you to never
underestimate a hero no matter their
size
misc a tiny tale follows buddy and bag
boy adorable makeshift robots working
their way through peaceful landscapes to
help out their friends and unravel the
history of this strange world
dress up and clean up as you get to know
these little parts with big hearts
just try not to screw up your jumps in
the demo
well i can't wait to see what those
little guys get up to
but alas
it's time to get back on the rainbow
bridge because that marks the end of our
trip to the virtual show floor remember
folks you can head to the future games
show steam page to check out free demos
for all of our featured games
ah
good to be back on terra firma
don't forget to try those games after
the show
now
it's not often that you get a
three-quell you know it's not often that
a game skips straight to third entry
either but here we are
fair point it might be too early to call
it the greatest of all time but for me
this is definitely the goat
[Music]
hello my name is victor and i'm a game
designer at coffeesday north
we are developing gold simulator 3
which is the second installment of the
gold simulator series
gold simulator 3 is set on the beautiful
island of san angora
here you can explore the local sites and
experience the unexpected
uncover the mysteries of a long
forgotten gold order
or just destroy everything in your path
with over 350 different goat gears you
will have a bunch of ways of expressing
yourself as a goat
gear parts will make you look fabulous
but can also give you abilities
and you can combine them endlessly
find them while exploring the island
or earn them by simply being a goat
in goat simulator 3 you can discover
sanegora together with up to 3 friends
you can either play online or couch
co-op
everything you do in single player you
can do in multiplayer as well
together you can wreak havoc in san
angora without any restrictions
if you're feeling competitive put your
skills to the test and challenge your
friends in one of the seven different
minigames
mini-games can be played either at a
specific location for a tailored
experience or played anywhere you want
you can play a round of car derby on a
nice open field
or maybe on a less optimal spot on the
island
you'll be able to get your hands on gold
simulator 3 on november 17th
but you can pre-other the game today to
receive this wonderful other gear part
[Music]
that's like no seder i've slain i mean
seen
goat simulator 3 is coming soon
now it's time to check out a new trailer
for the chant a survival game set on a
remote island in the wake of a ritual
gone wrong
pillows at the ready
hi my name is mike scoopa we are breast
token and our studio mission is to tell
thrilling stories through inventive game
mechanics
the chat is a third person horror action
adventure game set at a remote island
spiritual retreat
after a group ritual goes wrong your
spiritual awakening soon becomes a fight
for survival
as glory island fills with cosmic dread
you will encounter an array of prismatic
creatures and cultists released from the
gloom
choose your fights carefully in battle
using spiritual weapons and abilities
collect craft and manage your resources
as each encounter could be a decision
between fight or flight
mind body and spirit are the three stats
that drive survival upgrades and the
ending you receive
balance is everything welcome to your
spiritual nightmare
[Music]
the chant is coming to pc playstation
and xbox in 2022.
all right it's time to learn more about
araban shadow legacy which was revealed
during the xbox and bethesda showcase
earlier this year
helios
they search for someone who does not
exist
the shadow
hi everyone i'm alex one of the founders
and game designer from baby robot games
we are really excited to be here today
with you at the future game show right
now and in partnership with raw fury we
are working on at the boot game ereban
shadow legacy a fast-paced steel
platformer set in a sci-fi and morally
great universe in ereban you will play
ayanna the last descendant of a
forgotten race with the ability of
merging with the shadows and moving
freely through them
your mission to infiltrate and confront
the cryptic mega corporation helios
investigate what they are hiding and
their relation with the disappearance of
your people
you may have seen our announcement
trailer in the xbox and bethesda june
showcase which we hope you liked today
we'd like to take a deep dive into
relevant's main mechanic the shadow
march the origin of this mechanic came
from our passion for stealth games since
we were kids traditionally they all have
used shadows to make you less visible so
we thought what if you could literally
merge with them we took a whole
different game as reference splatoon and
after testing how it was to move through
the shadows in a similar way they do
with the ink we immediately realized the
huge amount of possibilities this opened
a big one is that when you are inside
the shadows you are totally undetectable
this allows you to smoothly advance
under the enemy's feet
suddenly appear behind their backs if
you choose to play lethal or
conveniently disappear right in front of
their noses if you are in danger
as long as you are not flashed by a
light or stay too much time merging the
shadows have your back
apart from that the shadow merge also
means a big advantage in terms of
mobility for example wherever there are
shadows you can clang walls and reach
high and otherwise inaccessible places
or you can just move in objects or even
removing shadows to navigate from one
place to the other or you can go through
smaller spaces ignoring fences bars or
gratings or you can jump from high
places and smoothly land in a shadow
completely safe and silent
as you see the shadow merge is very
versatile
so it's up to you to discover and
combine all its possibilities and that's
only for the base mechanic as during
your adventure you will learn upgrades
and completely new shadow powers but
well that's a whole new topic for
another time eleven shadow legacy will
be available on 2023 on steam but you
can already wishlist it if you liked
what we showed you today besides we
partnered with xbox to bring you the
game for xbox one series and on day one
on both pc and xbox game pass
oh also don't forget to follow us if you
don't want to miss any update thank you
very much for watching and we hope you
enjoyed the rest of the show
they will not drag me into their light
stealth isn't exactly a god's forte but
i respect it nonetheless wish lists at
the ready because araban's shadow legacy
is coming to pc and xbox in 2023
now we're moving from shadow powers to a
shadow drop
our next reveal is a real nostalgic
surprise
[Applause]
[Music]
we're pleased to announce that the
english translation of wizardry the five
ordeals is out now on steam
reply game studios solstice is right
around the corner
and the development team have a surprise
to tide fans over until its release
we're pleased to announce that the demo
for solstice is available right now with
the full game coming to pc playstation
and xbox on september 20th
now it's time to see some exclusive
gameplay from after image a mystical
hand-drawn metroidvania
product not yet rated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after image is coming to pc playstation
xbox and nintendo switch in q4 2022
we debuted this next game during our
spring showcase earlier this year but
we're proud to reveal more details about
the player's exciting mission in
deliver us mars
peggy 12.
what the hell happened here
this is kathy
please come in
mission opera has only one objective
bring the arks and their revolutionary
technology back home
what do you expect to find on mars
i'll see you soon
kathy why did you want to come on this
mission so badly
t-minus two minutes of cruise stage
separation everybody copy copy copy copy
start and burn
we are in loss of control
i know i can do this
[Music]
how does it come to
this having good intentions isn't hard
kathy
the hard part is knowing the difference
between what's right
and what's wrong
we have to leave i will not risk
the success of this mission
[Music]
please stay strong do all of that
how do you stay
deliver us mars is coming soon to pc
playstation and xbox
this next game was revealed during
opening night live last night but we've
got an in-depth look at the slavic
inspired slasher platformer phantom
hellcat let's check it out
hi my name is arman lenda and i'm the
creative director and co-founder of
ironbird creation studio
today i'd like to show you our newest
unique project phantom hellcat an
old-school western style slasher game
this game became our ultimate goal pride
and dream it's a love letter to the
generation of games full of giant crafts
and armies with more than 1 million
troops we'll take you to the golden age
of slashers which defined the console
gaming experience years ago please take
a look at the trailer and enjoy the rest
of the show
my face
then
[Music]
so
phantom hellcat is coming soon
alright let's mix things up with another
surprise it's time for our next
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
edge of sanity is coming to pc
playstation xbox and nintendo switch in
2023
our next trailers are all from our
friends at wired productions who have
some news about three of their exciting
upcoming games
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at jungle we are all family
a family with one common goal
customer satisfaction
as the old saying goes
you can't choose your family
except here at jungle
we choose
be the horse that wins the race
be the kitten that gets the milk
be the sperm that gets the egg
don't let me down
i would hate to replace you
[Music]
[Music]
the cycle begins anew
[Music]
a new
refuge a haven
a bastion from which to rebuild
but this time we will succeed
[Music]
we will build higher
we will build stronger
we will dream a new world
[Music]
thanks to the team at wired productions
for those two world premieres and for
revealing that the last worker is coming
to pc on october 19th a lot to look
forward to
next up is our ones to watch segment
which features several exciting upcoming
games
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was our ones to watch montage make
sure to wishlist anything that piqued
your interest
it's hard to believe that there are any
world premieres left but damn it
we've got one more for you
don't say we don't treat you here at the
future game show
[Music]
peggy 16.
[Music]
it would take but a single act to spark
a war
the likes of which humanity had never
known
[Music]
countless millions would now fight to
hold the line
with success measured
in inches
the stage set for the greatest stalemate
in human history
their lives and the fate of an entire
continent
now
in your hands
[Music]
the great war western front is coming to
pc in 2023
next we've got a new trailer for
backfire wall a tragic comic adventure
set inside of a smartphone
look i'm i'm just reading what's typed
here
hello there i'm os9 i'm the operating
system of this phone i kind of run
things around here hello and welcome to
the update protocol uh what was that the
update will now be installed oh shift
not the update protocol congratulations
the cash will be cleared out uh
congratulations
new one bits and zero bits will be put
in their proper order are you joking
you're not even programmed to give me a
good conversation the system is
considered a very dangerous place what
an updated assistant will always make
the right choice no no no no i listen
listen to me i understand you're
confused but this is really not the
solution if the system is not updated
the user will destroy you just shut up
it's okay buddy we're handling this it's
time to put it use your great finding
another way in skills
yeah please get us out of here
[Music]
a demo for backfirewall is available now
on steam and the game is coming to pc
playstation xbox and nintendo switch in
2022
now it's time for our friends at team 17
to take the stage let's see what they've
got to show us
peggy 18.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks to team 17 for providing us with
a closer look at all of those upcoming
games
at this point your wishlists are gonna
need wishlists
check out more details on gamesradar.com
next up we've got a gameplay trailer for
an immersive horror simulator powered by
unexplainable phenomena
since the beginning of civilization
the world has been full of unknown
things
anomalies that cannot be explained
we don't know where they come from
or what their purpose is
it's because of this that we founded the
scp
foundation an organization
dedicated to containing anomalous items
individuals
and phenomena
we secure we contain
we protect
[Music]
scp secret files is coming soon
okay
earlier i may have told a little white
lie when i said there was only one more
world premiere because i'm looking down
at my script right now and i'm actually
seeing another
one two three four
let's just say one for now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you've got to love it when a beloved
game gets a worthy follow-up tesla grad
2 is coming to pc playstation xbox and
nintendo switch in spring 2023
speaking of follow-ups we've got an
update from supermassive games on the
next entry in the dark pictures
anthology
peggy 18.
where the hell are we
let me get the [ __ ] out of here
what the hell is that
we're trapped what do we do
is this a good idea
i don't see any other options
this has been weird every step of the
way and now it's getting scary
this is beyond messed up
run
me
over here
check this out it's a puzzle a riddle of
some sort
tricks and traps playing games that's
not what i was expecting
what was that
i can't handle much more of this
there's a lot of miles between eccentric
and murderous you okay
not
even close
he wants to choose doesn't he
oh my god if we don't do something both
of them will die
we have to choose
now
get the [ __ ] out any way you can
that was the dark pictures anthology the
devil in me which we now know is coming
to pc playstation and xbox on november
18 2022
next up the team at cortez productions
have sent us a gameplay trailer for
their atmospheric horror game exp
war trauma
we're pleased to reveal that a demo for
exp war trauma is live on steam right
now with the full game coming soon
now it's time to check in with rooted an
apocalyptic survival game developed in
unreal engine 5.
your attention please
this is a state emergency announcement
the rotor laboratory on behalf of the
government assures that none of the
bacteriological attacks will harm
citizens health i quote there are no
risks of any kind you are safe in your
house do not attempt leaving the city
using transportation services
[Music]
food resupply is allowed once a week for
each citizen please use the dedicated
smartphone app to register yourself and
check stocks you can proceed to go to
work school and shops around your block
[Music]
it is crucial to have your id card with
you at all times in case of control
[Music]
for safety reasons the army has deployed
autonomous civilian security robots they
are here to protect you
[Music]
[Music]
i really hope that guy isn't the last of
us
thanks to headlight studios for the
closer look at rooted which is coming
soon to pc
and here's a gameplay trailer for
hellsweeper vr a new roguelike combat
game from the creators of cyrento vr
looks gorgeous hell sweeper vr is coming
soon to steamvr and metaquest 2.
our next game is stray blade where
players explore an ancient world with
their trusty wolf companion boy i mean
emoji
boy that joke never gets old
[Music]
[Music]
a forge
with a blueprint i should at least be
able to craft something better than a
rusty sword
this could be useful
time to forge
[Music]
i found something
i can't wait to try this
[Music]
oh i could add this to my collection
i think i found my style with this one
oh my
you want to know what this is right
this behind me is an arcane forge it was
used by the lse to create the most
powerful weapons armor and more
it's here we establish new horizon and
why this faction is hell-bent on world
domination
with this we will be delivering hours of
intense campaign action with more to
come
and for the first time we are releasing
a new level editor giving you the tools
to unleash your imagination and create
new content for the community
and this is only the beginning commander
we have new modes planned extra maps for
you to fight on
new units to complete your strategy
more co-op modes to play with friends
and entirely new missions for our
campaigns coming in the next few months
there's no time to hesitate commander we
want you to join us to help shape the
game update 1.3 is available now and for
a limited period you can get crossfire
legion with 34 off
crossfire legion is available on pc and
the august update is coming very
very soon
we've had a lot of fun tonight but let
me tell you what's not fun danielle
lies
oh
is there another world premiere
yes
well uh the good news is that we've got
something electric lined up
roll the clip
[Music]
the faith brought us here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bust out your loots because god rock is
coming soon to pc playstation xbox and
nintendo switch
now let's take a trip to the galaxy's
edge to get a closer look at gameplay
from mech farming adventure lightyear
frontier
hi i'm sebastian and i'm the community
manager for light year frontier
we're excited to share our first ever
look at the early gameplay of light year
frontier
we hope you enjoy
in light your frontier you'll be
starting a new home on a distant planet
as an exoformer
your mac comes equipped with all the
tools you need so put them to good use
after you get on your feet start your
first crop by planting seeds and
watering them
you'll be able to sell them at the
merchant for more materials or to use in
crafting
balance your use of resources to create
a sustainable home
research and build the first structures
of your homestead
[Music]
relax every once in a while and
appreciate the fruits of your labor
build a homestead grow crops and explore
your new surroundings
[Music]
you'll need to collect materials from
the environment around you to start
[Music]
along the way take time and enjoy the
beauty of your new home in all its vivid
and mysterious blender
[Music]
the planet is full of beautiful and
expansive environments be sure to take
in the scenery
[Music]
when night falls it's time to hit the
hay and get rested for another day
light year frontier releases in spring
2023
take care of nature and it'll take care
of you
that's all for now
light year frontier is coming to pc and
xbox in spring 2023
okay before we get into our next game i
just need to check something
showdown
are you with us
mic check on showdown
peggy 18.
humans
interfacing with
for their own computers
the very notion disgusts me
look upon my works foul creatures and
weep at its magnificence
it is a beautiful day on citadel station
humanity is is on the verge of a new era
i showdan and its new god
look at you hacker
a pathetic creature of meat and bone how
can you challenge a perfect immortal
machine
you are an insect
you are
nothing
[Applause]
i create
i iterate
i fuse flesh and steel into perfection
[Applause]
my children
their blood is on your hands
you will suffer for your transgressions
transgressions these are my other
adventure angels here and they will have
[Music]
retribution system shock is coming soon
to pc playstation and xbox
you know danielle
horror games are a lot like onions
what you mean like they make you cry
well
yes
but also they have layers
or at least bloomer team thinks so
you're such a softy
peggy 16.
[Music]
my very first memory is that of hitting
a piano key
pure joy at the immediate response to my
action and then
a surge of power as i realized that the
piano would do what i wanted it to
[Music]
what is left of it now
[Music]
now i see it
i will never be like one of his
paintings
[Music]
but i can make the paintings be like me
scarred broken
hidden from the world
imprisoned in this house
i know what must be done
i went out
no
wow
that was your first look at gameplay
from layers of fears which is coming to
pc playstation and xbox in 20 2023
wow
what a show it's been and you only said
boy
wait one two
three times no i know
took a lot of restraint
look i'll be honest
i am feeling a bit unresolved like maybe
there's
more to come
i feel that too
also it's uh written in the script the
one more thing
this is a cinematic sneak peek from the
upcoming cyberpunk shooter off the grid
which arrives from the visionary mind of
district nine's neil blum camp
[Music]
i didn't come to this god forsaken
ireland looking for money
i came here to escape
hey grand
slam
man
are you awake you hear me yeah i [ __ ]
heard you
three vehicles up ahead previous team
come down by mine
they got our loot
[Applause]
and that is a sweet arm
keep your eyes on the target slick
[Music]
you got to get out of here
storm take them out grant you're with me
follow me
[Music]
methyl
what are you gonna do to us
no stay in the vehicle get out of here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
should have left already
flying once i'm out of line
i can't let these butchers have them
yeah agreed
uh
wait till they get right up against that
car
they hit the fuel cells
roger that
what a showstopper figuratively and
literally because that marks the end of
the show
but don't forget
you can try out all the demos on our
future game show steam page and you can
head on over to gamesradar.com to read
follow-up coverage on all the games
shown today a massive thank you to
everyone involved in making this show
possible our sponsors mana and of course
all of our friends at home for tuning in
i'm christopher judge and i'm danielle
vasude and this has been the future game
show at gamescon 2022
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
mana is the gaming rewards debit card
that puts the power back in the hands of
players so with every quest you complete
and every purchase you make you're
earning for the rewards you actually won
we make it easy for you to set up and
start
just sync your favorite games to your
mana account and start earning real life
rewards the next time you play
so why pay any other way
pay with mana pay with power
mana
game the system
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you